في مثل هذه الاحوال الماساويه عاده ما
يتبادر الى الاذهان الاجراءات التي يجب
اتباعها في مثل هذه الحالات ويبدو ان هناك
الكثير من سبل الحمايه في مثل هذه الاوقات
منها ما هو قبل الهزه كتحديد اماكن امنه
في الخارج بعيدا عن الابنيه والاشجار وعدم
التوجه الى المناطق الساحليه خوفا من حدوث
موجات مد عاتيه اما اثناء الهزه فلا تبادر
الى الخروج او النزول الى الملجا فالبقاء
في الداخل اسلم ابتعد عن النوافذ واحمل
راس والوجه بما امكن وفي حال كان الشخص
خارج المنزل وفي السياره يجب ركن السياره
بعيدا عن المباني والامدادات الكهربائيه
العامه وعدم عبور الجسور ودخول الانفاق
اما بعد حصول الهزه فاذا كنت مصابا حافظ
على هدوئك وتجنب صدمات الخوف والهلع واذا
لم تتعرض لاي اصابه اخمد الصغيره واقطع
جميع مصادر الطاقه واستعد لحدوث هزات
ارتداديه قبل حدوثها
وهل الحديث اكثر وتفاصيل اوفى من الشارقه
ينضم الينا الدكتور زيد السعدون استاذ قسم
الهندسه المدنيه بكليه الهندسه جامعه
الشارقه تخصص الهندسه الانشائيه
والزلزاليه دكتور زيد يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
معنا في صباح العربيه احيانا النظريات صعب
تطبيقها اثناء الفاجعه والكارثه والمصيبه
عندما تحل ولكن هل يمكن الحديث عن طريقه
مثلى طريقه صحيحه يمكن ان نحمي بها انفسنا
في حال وقوع الزلازل
نعم شكرا جزيلا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
انما حدث في الزلزال في تركيا واجزاء اخرى
حقيقه المنا كثيرا
وخاصه الذين فقدوا حياتهم والذين هم في
اعداد المصابين كما تفضلتي اخت نادين
هنالك بعض الاجراءات الوقائيه التي يمكن
ان يقوم بها الشخص قبل حدوث الزلزال
واثناء الزلزال وبعد الزلزال اذا كان في
داخل البيت او في خارج البيت
كما تفضلتي قبل الزلزال طبعا الزلزال يحدث
على مدى فترات قد مثلا زلزال في تركيا
الان استمر لمده دقيقتين فخلال هذه المده
يعني يجب الانسان الواعي فيتطلب من الجهات
المدنيه والجهات في كل بلده ان تثقف الناس
على ماذا يفعلون والاسعافات الاوليه اثناء
مواجهه هذه الكوارث
اولا في حال حدوث الزلزال هل يجب ان ابقى
مكاني
نعم اذا كنت في المنزل ومع الاسف الذي
يعني قدر الله سبحانه وتعالى ان الزلزال
كان في الوقت الصباح الباكر فمعظم الناس
كانوا راقدين
والزلزال استغرق حوالي دقيقتين فمثلا لو
كان هناك والشخص في المنازل معظم الناس
كانوا في المنازل او لا الانخفاض
والاحتماء بالسرير كمثل ان يحتمل انسان
تحت منضده او الى لم يوجد منضده يحتمي
بشيء صلب لا يقع عليه وان لم يجد فيحتمي
بنفسه اي يعني يضم يديه
وينزل راسه ويبتعد عن الزجاج والنوافذ قدم
الاستطاعه لان هذه كلها تحدث على على يعني
فكرات قصيره يعني اذا كان في السرير فيبقى
في مكانه ويحتمي ولو بوساده لا يقف عند
المداخن المداخل الابواب الا يعني يتاكد
انها
اذا كانت هنالك جدران وهنالك خرسانه مسلحه
فيقف تحت الاجزاء التي تكون قويه ويعني
مسلحه وليست من المباني
نعم انا خارج المنزل مثلا في الشارع وفي
السياره ماذا يجب علينا ان افعل ايضا
طبعا انا بس اذا كنت فطران بس اريد اكمل
لو كنت في الداخل عدم استخدام المصاعد
والابتعاد عن الاجهزه الكهربائيه
هذه كتبتها اما سؤالك اذا كنت في الخارج
فاذا طبعا في الخارج اذا كنت تقولين
السياره ام كنت ماشيه ماشيه فاذا كنت يعني
في الخارج اول شيء تتحرك الشخص يتحرك بعيد
عن المباني وعن الاعمده والاسلاك
الكهربائيه
ويقف ولا يتحرك حتى تنتهي الهزه الارضيه
هذا اذا كان ماشيا اما اذا كان يقود
السياره فافضل شيء ان يتوقف في منطقه بعيد
عن المباني ويظل في السياره ويظل في
السياره ويتجنب الوقوف بالقب او من اسفل
المباني ويبتعد عن الجسور لان الجسور وهو
في السياره هي جسور طبعا اثناء الزلزال
تتحرك قواعد الجسور ويؤدي الى سقوط الجسر
لا سمح الله
فيبتعد عن هذا ويقف جانبا في مكان يعني
امن وينتظر ويدعو الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يفرج هذه الكوربه طب دكتور زيد اذا كنت
اعيش مثلا في منطقه ساحليه مثلا في
اللاذقيه السوريه هل يجب علي ان اترك
المنطقه فورا
حقيقه هي اه دائره الارصاد الزلزاليه في
كل منطقه تعطي تنبؤات لكن احنا نعرف ان
الزلزال لا احد يعرف متى يقع ولكن نعرف ان
المنطقه تعرفين الزلازل هي السبع صفائح
ارضيه فعندما يحدث الزلزال بسبب تمدد
القشره الارضيه هناك طاقه تريد ان تتمدد
فيحدث الزلزال الزلزال اذا اذا كان مقره
في البحر فيؤدي الى موجات موجات هذه
الموجات يعني تسبب تسونامي كما اطلق عليها
فاذا انت في منطقه ساحليه طبعا لا يجب ان
تصمم المباني الان احنا في قسم الهندسه
المدنيه نعلم الطلاب في الدراسات العليا
كيف يصممون المباني لمقاومه الزلازل
مقاومه
مقاومه الزلازل ومقاومه ما ينتج عنها من
تسونامي اذا كانت مناطق قريبه على البحر
فحيكون تاثير الاحمال اللي جايه من من
الماء واذا كانت في اليابسه التاثير
الاحمال اللي الافقيه اللي جايه من
الزلازل فهي عمليه عمليه اول شيء وعي من
ماذا يفعل الانسان اثناء حصول الكارثه
عمليه
مباني كيف نصمم المباني لتحمل هذه الاحمال
هذه النقطه اللي اشرتها ربما ستاخذ منحه
اخر حوار جديد نريد ان نفتحه معك الان
عندما تتحدث عن مساله المباني اليوم
بالهندسه هل فعلا يمكن القول بانه هذا
مبنى مضاد للزلازل ويمكن انشائه بناء على
هذا الاساس
نعم طبعا
الكود او المعيار الزلزالي للابنيه تطور
مع الزمن انشئ في بدايه القرن الماضي ثم
تطور في بدايه السبعينات
البحوث تم اضافه المتطلبات لانشاء المباني
لكي تتحمل الزلازل من خلال ماذا من خلال
التصميم من خلال
الخرسانه المسلحه التي نضعها في
المباني الكوميديه او المباني الحديديه
فهذه عباره عن تهيئه المباني لمقام في
الزلازل واحنا نرى الان في جميع الدول ان
هذه المطلبات الزلزاليه تتطور الان بعد
الذي حصل في تركيا اكيد سيكون هنالك خبراء
وباحثون
تاثير هذا الزلزال وماذا يمكن ان يعمل
الذي حصل في تركيا وفي مناطق شمال سوريا
ان هذه المباني كثير منها قديمه لم تنشا
يعني لمقاومه الزلازل وكذلك كثير من
الباني في شمال سوريا نتيجه للظروف التي
مر فيها البلد وهي تصدعت وكثير من الناس
هم ساكنين فيها
وسكنوا هذه سكنوا هذه المباني فهي مباني
يعني غير مؤهله للسكن وجاء جاءت هذا
الزلزال
فسبب هذه الكارثه وندعو الله لهم يعني
بالرحمه وندعو للمصابين بالشفاء العاجل
ودكتور زيد يعني حتى نعود لموضوعنا
الاساسي يقال بانه كثره الضحايا ايضا
للبعض الزلازل هو بسبب ليس فقط بدرجه
الاولى ايضا بسبب الزلزال بل بسبب التصرف
غير السليم او غير الصحيح اثناء وبعد
الزلزال بلا شك مثلا اذا حصل الزلزال يجب
على الانسان ان لا يتحرك وكما قلنا ان
يبتعد عن النوافذ يبتعد عن اسلاك
الكهربائيه اذا كان في المطبخ يجب ان يغلق
كل كل ما من شان الطباخ الغاز يبحث عن
مكان يعني هذا الشيء اذا كان في المبنى
وتعرض للزلزال لا يخرج من المبنى يظل في
مكانه ويحاول ان يستتر بشيء صلب
هذا فهي عمليه عمليه يعني مجتمعه تثقيف
تثقيف للناس ماذا يفعلون اثناء اثناء وقبل
وبعد هناك نقطه مهمه انه هنالك يجب ان
تكون خطه في قبل حدود الزلزال ماذا نعمل
لو حصل الزلزال كاحنا عائله في البيت
كاحنا مؤسسه ماذا نعمل نتفق انه لا سمح
الله لو اصبح هذا الزلزال كنا نحتمي تحت
هذا الدرج مثلا
فهي خطه قبل حدود الزلزال خطه اثناء وخطه
بعد وكذلك مجتمعي حكومي وتثقيف اسري ايضا
على صعيد الافراد الكثير من النقاط شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور زيد سعدون استاذ قسم
الهندسه المدنيه